we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail that came in over the weekend
kind of a personal question but that's
okay i'll entertain it have you ever
been abused by the popo stories please
it's possible yeah I have not I have not
I have had interactions with police
probably I don't know if you account for
getting pulled over instances where I
was near an incident and ended up
talking to police and of course the
infamous half beer four months shy of my
21st birthday arrest incident which I've
described before I've probably had about
ten interactions with police and no I
mean they haven't been I've never been
abused and I recognized when I am
interacting with police I will if I
think police if I get pulled over um has
happened about a year ago and I think
that a police officer is giving me a
hard time just because they kind of feel
like it uh I will give them a hard time
I will not treat them with the exact
deference that they may want and I
recognize that I'm willing to do that
because whether or not I'm white or not
you know being in a Jewish immigrant
from Argentina who grew up speaking
Spanish whatever I am perceived as just
a white guy who's not a threat to police
officers and so I recognize that I'm
more comfortable talking to police
officers in a way that is not the way
North Koreans talked to Kim jong-un
right I mean I just talk to them like
they're normal people there's no that I
am respectful of everybody I talk to you
but I'm not deferential in a way as if
I'm dealing with royalty I understand
that not everybody would do that because
of their position but no I have not had
any situation with police that I would
consider remotely abusive or violent or
anything of the sorts and I'm guessing
that that probably doesn't come as a
surprise to most people in the audience
but if I ever have that me to a moment
that a lot of the hatreds are waiting
for
or who knows what my interactions with
police will be like at that point we've
got a great bonus show for you today
there was this insane GoFundMe build the
wall campaign and it raised I think
millions of dollars and all of those
donations are going to be refunded
fortunately that's good news
we will also talk about it's not just
public defecation that's taking on at
national parks during the government
shutdown a bunch of protected trees are
also being cut down which is absolutely
horrible and the families of the Sandy
Hook shooting victims have won a legal
victory against Alex Jones and Infowars
that is a story we have been following
at this point for several years and we
have news all of which we will discuss
on today's bonus show how do you get
access to the bonus show it's easy
there's two ways you become a member at
WWJ impact mancom you become a patron
for at least five bucks a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show both
of those options give you instant access
to the bonus show if you like this show
causation correlation to different
things if you like this show I would
predict that you would love the
world-famous bonus show I'll speak to
you then